حسابات عربيه واسرائيليه في مواقع التواصل
تداولت مقطع فيديو من تغطيه قناه الجزيره
للقصف الاسرائيلي على محيط المستشفى
الاندونيسي ادعت انه يبرز افرادا من حركه
حماس يحملون اسلحه ناريه بالمستشفى وان
الجزيره حذفت الفيديو لاحقا الادعاء
تلقفته حسابات اسرائيليه رسميه وابرزت ضمن
حملتها لتبرير استهداف وقصف المستشفيات في
غزه بالبحث تبين ان الجزيره لم تحذف
الفيديو ولا يزال متاحا على منصتها في
يوتيوب وبتحليل المقطع تبين ان السلاح
المزعوم لا يحتوي على اجزاء السلاح
المعروفه كالمقدمة
[موسيقى]
ويعمل فيما يبدو على تنظيم الحركه في
المستشفى بالاضافه الى صور سابقه تظهر
استخدام قطاع الامن في غزه لتلك الهراوه
هذه الادعاءات وغيرها تاتي في سياق حمله
اسرائيليه شعواء ضد مستشفيات قطاع غزه
التي تعاني بالفعل من الحصار والقصف وقطع
الامدادات
l